j'accueille maintenant jacno
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
kiffer puise donc il ya kindle j'imagine
que c'est c'est vous qui ne jurent
cadillac cki cadillac qu'est cadillac
celui et mc salo m6 à l'hôtel
apparemment c'est lui voilà way son très
bien ses nouvelles recrues pas mes
nouvelles recrues tamanar disque a pas
du tout ah bon j'ai donné ma bénédiction
et parrain du oui j'ai dit c'est très
bien mais moi je n'ai rien à voir
darryl des bêtes et des animaux qu'elle
brûle en voir ce qu'ils font ils ont un
tube qui marche très très bien
qu'ils s'appellent je suis plus cheap à
fait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bah
voilà ça commence comme ça s'est su plus
de fuite alors on se dit ça y est on est
revenue en 77 à l'époque où j'étais
ringarde fumer des pétards ont dit ça y
est c'est l'époque qui reviennent mais à
un moment la chanson repart et ça
s'appelle georges fume du shit depuis
j'ai eu une conversation
tout seul dans mon coin
alors super cheap comme vous réinventer
votre légende à chaque interview j'ai
pas préparé de fiche parce que de toute
façon j'allais bien raison qui kahn a
inventé une connerie différentes ont
fait l'interview pas préparé oui bon ben
voilà c'est l'interview pas préparé
comment ça va
cd ben ouais pourquoi parce que rien ah
ouais d'accord dont vous êtes les
nouveaux bâtard du showbiz c'est ça
didon un peu de respect l'armée c'est un
signalement oui bah si tu veux aller
cinq musées icom vous voulez ou pas vous
mais d'où là tu viens d'où toi kayak
voyage fait bordeaux en dordogne ouais
ouais
célèbre pour son asile ouais vraiment eh
oui
m6 à l'eau il vient w nous sommes six à
l'eau il vient du mans vient du mans et
toi tu viens d'où kenshoo est bien de
paris ouais ouais c'est votre teint
jacno c'est votre parent c'est votre
marraine vous connaissez ce qu'il a fait
jacno com - ouais ouais ouais c'est
génial
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cet été
[Musique]
donc c'est vrai que c'était assez proche
de ce qu'ils font je comprend une
filiation brenets aucun rapport avec ces
jacques à ces jeux son prochain album
donc maintenant tu as essayé
art mengo marque et steve kent
la prochaine fois c'est stupeflip
exactions c'est vraiment stupéfiant
ouais c'est bien mais mais
c'est pas au point de vue me musiques et
rythmes sociaux ça me rappelle un peu
gainsbourg c'est william hague
mais je préfère gainsbourg ouais
carrément pour est ce que je pensais que
ces batteries qui est efficace
alors c'est vrai que c'était trop dur
non mais tu fais du théâtre et tout ça
c'est enrique
[Musique]